Recently, I've seen a lot of discourse about homeschool on the internet,
mostly fueled by the idea of unschooling,
or what if your kids are not really gonna be learning anything?
So I wanted to weigh in as a first time homeschool family,
a mom who never thought she would homeschool her kids,
that homeschooling shouldn't be less on the parent.
It's going to be more.
There are a lot of ways to do this,
but my ultimate goal with my kids was to give them a better education,
a more comprehensive education,
a more culturally diverse education
than the one they were gonna get at public school.
An education that is going to challenge them,
that is gonna broaden their horizons,
that is gonna allow them to have some
control of the subjects that they learn
while still balancing advancing them in all of the course subjects,
meaning a full, comprehensive education in math, science,
ELA, and social studies.
But the gift that it really gave me is the gift of time.
I now get to watch their little eyes light up
when they learn something new.
We get to explore a new subject together.
There are no field trip days, because any day could be a field trip day.
My husband and I have prioritized our life in a way that
he has time when he takes it off of work,
and I'm home all the time.
So we are able to constantly be teaching our kids.
Now Whether or not you believe in the UN school approach,
I will tell you what we do.
I follow a curriculum.
I outsource certain subjects to experts in the field.
We take trips and field trips and hands on learning very seriously,
and we allow our kids to dive into things that they're interested in.
I think there are amazing things about homeschooling,
and if you're curious,
you can message me.